for the first time in nearly a week we
saw president trump yesterday at a
veterans day ceremony at arlington
national cemetery
he did not make any remarks at that time
and sources tell cbs news the outgoing
president
has not attended a meeting of the white
house coronavirus task force in months
they say that he's been distracted by
the election
and the meetings have lacked substance
paula reed is at the white house with
more on this story paula good morning to
you what are you hearing today
good morning gail the task force is
still holding meetings
but senior administration officials tell
cbs news
not much is actually happening during
these meetings
even as the country sets these new daily
records
for infections on monday vice president
mike pence chaired a meeting where
officials they were really focused
on distribution of therapeutics and
vaccines
but there's still no coherent message or
strategy from the white house
on how to slow the spread now in one
interview dr anthony fauci he admitted
that the transition between
president trump and president-elect
biden it's been tense
earlier this week we saw president trump
he fired his defense secretary
and there are concerns that the
president could try to fire some of
these top health officials
on the task force like his political
appointees fda commissioner stephen hahn
or his hhs secretary alex azar
the president cannot directly fire dr
anthony fauci or other career officials
but he can remove them from the task
force but
president-elect joe biden he would have
the option of putting them
back into whatever group he forms to
address this pandemic
tony dr fauci may have some other job
offers if he loses the one he currently
has paul
thank you very much